obviously jd one of the greatest
producers of all time but specifically
when it comes to the r b [ __ ] he's
i mean i don't know man he might be the
goat you know i mean you think of
confessions and i mean [ __ ] jd's
that [ __ ]
what was the initial like uh
link up with jd and like having him
handle
a lot of the reigns on the project it
wasn't supposed to be that on on first
meet up we were really just meeting my
our um
management team just set up
you know me going through the go say
what up to him right meet jermaine
dupree
and you know fast forward
two three days and it's like
you know
we're together every day right you know
we talk every day you know the
relationships turn from
hero to you know big bro [ __ ] yeah you
know like i don't think there's a day
that goes by we're not calling or
texting about whatever it is you know at
this point what is something that you
guys learn creatively
from jd because you know when you're
like that prolific i feel like i'm sure
a lot of the stuff he does just seems
like effortlessly but at the end of the
day you could probably grab from
oh being around that i think it is that
though everything he does seems so
effortless
that when we're with him he's always
telling us we're thinking too hard
you'll be the first to be like bro
you're thinking about this way too hard
if you haven't got her by now either
move on or it's that thing right there
you know so that's his like
hit formula he can tell you in like 10
seconds yeah that's going to go now
that's not the one
it's the craziest thing with him and and
it it really shows in this record
because
what i like to say that i think he's
great at is
is real genius and what i mean by that
is
there's a level of genius that i think
that is
for
intel intellectual people to catch
but i think there's another higher tier
where even if you're not smart you still
recognize the genius right and he's a
way that like finds a way of making
everything genius so simple well that
like a kid can get it right yeah and
that's what i'm saying he's just like
he's just great his record's supposed to
be palatable to everybody they should be
right yeah exactly so and i think that
we've always
i think that's something that we really
um
could have always used some of that
because i think sometimes we've made
like almost higher intellectual
r b even it's just like we gotta we
gotta think oh we really listen to
intelligent sometimes the music from
from our perspective and i think he was
very
clear with us about like yo whatever you
guys have been doing is beautiful music
but let's make things that kind of go
across the board like people need to
understand it on the most basic level
they don't need to be able to they don't
have to like break it down to be like
well this this and this happened that's
why that's tied into this line over here
you know it's sometimes if someone just
can just stop you and just be like yo
exactly what you said there just leave
it like that he's great at that and not
overthinking it exactly and he's like yo
for the spot in rmb that you
want to go take and then i can see that
you
you have what it takes to go take that
this is the way to go it's like no
different than like you know like i
don't know kendrick lamar and like
section 80 which was [ __ ] one of my
favorite kendrick projects right but
then on goodki mad city he like put some
like hit he put some thought into like
you know some hits i guess
he took it oh my god he took away
further for sure i also was like
pimp a butterfly he said [ __ ] it i'm
doing me
damn he got to it you know that's true
by the way that's my timmy butterflies
my favorite kendrick album for the
record yes